قمم عربيه في السعوديه
اكتوبر من عام
قمه الرياض الطارئه بدعوه من السعوديه
والكويت وبمشاركه كل من مصر وسوريا ولبنان
ومنظمه التحرير الفلسطينيه
[موسيقى]
مارس من عام 2007 القمه العربيه العاديه
التاسعه عشره عقدت بالرياض بحضور 17 زعيما
عربيا ونتجت عنها قرارات تخص القضيه
الفلسطينيه والعراق
ابريل من عام 2018
القمه العربيه العاديه التاسعه والعشرون
عقدت في الظهران واعلنت السعوديه خلالها
تبرعها ب 200 مليون دولار لفلسطين
مايو من عام 2019
قمه مكه المكرمه لاستثنائيه بحثت التحديات
التي تمر بها المنطقه
وتداعياتها على الامن والسلم الاقليمي
والدوري
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات